to see
any child die is heartbreaking
but to see children dying
i think it was a rhetor and carrier
from starvation and from being frozen to
death
not only breaks your heart but makes you
angry that this is avoidable
and that these are unnecessary deaths
and that we have a duty of care of
course we have to blame the taliban
but when you see such a level of
suffering
you've got to act
and of course the way we must do this
now
is that all the western nations that
were part of the afghanistan effort must
come together and they must provide the
four billion of humanitarian aid that is
being asked for so that we can have
proper health care
so we can feed children and families and
so girls can go back to school and it's
now urgent in the next few days
that the british government take a lead
call a pledging conference bring these
countries together get the money out
there and it is possible to avoid what
is a winter of starvation
and the loss of hundreds of thousands of
lives unnecessarily but how to deal with
the political situation how to deal with
the taliban if the resources are sent
into afghanistan at the moment the
danger is that the
taliban appropriated it doesn't go to
the people that need it that's why
sanctions are in place
no you're wrong uh
the the aid can get through through ngos
through the united nations organizations
i'm in direct touch with the un
humanitarian coordinator he can get aid
in through unicef he can get aid in
through a number of organizations like
save the children at the international
rescue committee the red cross all these
organizations can operate within
afghanistan without giving credibility
or legitimacy to the taliban and i think
it's just a myth that is being
perpetuated across here that the only
way to get aid to people in afghanistan
is to get it through the taliban now of
course there are issues that have got to
be dealt with and i'm very happy to
address them but the important point is
that when you see suffering you can do
something about it and the ngos and the
un organizations are there and ready to
act but what they don't have is the
money to do so
and very few countries have given enough
money
to meet what has been a humanitarian
appeal that came before christmas uh
from the united nations for 4.4 billion
dollars
to allow them to feed 23 million people
and the longer we wait in giving the
money that's necessary and this can only
be done by calling countries together in
some sort of pledging conference the
longer we wait the more people will die
and the more this will encourage
terrorists the more this will encourage
the heroin trade because that's the only
occupation where people are making money
in afghanistan and the more we will see
mass migration out of afghanistan with
all the problems that that entails so
it's not only a moral duty on our part
it's enlightened self-interest for us to
act it's interesting what you say mr
brown there about then the the
infrastructure is in place through the
ngos it's it's more about the lack of
resources the lack of money being
pledged then what though are the
obstacles within afghanistan you did
allude to let's explore those a little
bit further
well let's first of all be clear that
countries could give money now
and that's the biggest issue that your
audience will be wanting to think about
how can we help stop
uh nadia orezza these girls starving to
death or being frozen to death how can
we give the medical treatment to
girls in hospital as the babies are born
and we saw the difficult birth without
the medical equipment that really was
necessary to make sure that our life was
going to be safe now this is our
responsibility we can talk all night
about what uh we think about the taliban
we can talk all night about what we
should do about the sanctions regime
i've got many ideas about that but the
important thing surely is this uh that
your reporter alex crawford has bravely
brought these photographs to us these
pictures of such suffering and there is
a duty on our part to do something about
it
but but you you did say you would
explore further any of the obstacles in
afghanistan because you know when we're
talking about little girls like that
there is a question isn't there of
course there is about what happens
hopefully they and hundreds of thousands
of others survive what happens when they
want to go to the school of their choice
any school indeed what happens when they
want to to marry the person that they
want to what happens if they then decide
that they want to not wear the dress
that the taliban want them to wear these
are important questions as well mr brown
yes and of course and there are extra
judicial killings and nobody can support
the oppressive repressive
policies toward women and girls of the
taliban regime and you'll notice that i
said the taliban is to blame right at
the beginning for what is going on here
but the the important thing to recognize
is that we can put pressure to get girls
back to school i'm actually chairman of
education cannot wait which is the
organization that's helping
girls particularly who are displaced and
who are refugees and with unicef working
in afghanistan education cannot wait
working many ngos working the taliban
have now set a date for teenage girls to
be able to go back to school on march
the 23rd
and we must ensure that the money is
there for these schools to be open
so that these girls can go back now we
can lay down conditions and say no money
will come unless the girls can actually
go to school
but what would be unfair i think to the
girls into their future is to say that
we are going to do nothing having spent
20 years in afghanistan saying we're
there to help the afghan people i think
it's our duty to continue to offer help
subject to the conditions that i'm
laying down okay and can you see a time
coming when the taliban can be should be
recognized as the
legitimate government of afghanistan
well i think there are discussions
taking place in norway at the moment as
you know and
the question of what kind of
representative government afghanistan is
going to have in the future is still
still an issue but really for me
watching these pictures uh tonight that
is not the main immediate issue
and while people may want to make this a
political issue
this is actually a humanitarian issue
it's about saving lives that are about
to be lost
it's about a winter when every day more
and more people are going to die and i
repeat the only way to get money that
will help
provide food and provide health care and
get the schools open is for the
international community to come together
it is quite shocking that after so many
months almost six months since the
taliban took over and we've seen this
humanitarian crisis and warned about it
there has been no pledging conference
organized by any single country prime
minister or president when the need is
so obvious
and it's of a humanitarian issue that
has got to be resolved so the first
thing that i want to see happen is the
prime minister of britain talks to the
european union and to joe biden in
america they arrange a pledging
conference get the money in show that we
can help people and save lives and i do
think that would stand us in good stead
for any negotiations we've got to have
in the future we do not need to
recognize the legitimacy of the taliban
regime to get aid to people who are
suffering do you think that that uh lack
of planning for the humanitarian
situation is a function of the the
overall chaotic withdrawal there wasn't
much planning for that either was there
well i think we've learned a lot from
what happened in august but again you
know we've got to look forward this is a
matter of hours and days not a matter of
months and years
and we can sit speculating in london
about what's uh the right or the wrong
uh attitude that was taken by joe biden
in august what we've got to do is face
up to the humanitarian crisis that
resulted and the longer the west runs
away from the actions uh that uh have
now
befallen the what's befallen the afghan
people the more we will suffer in the
long run because these extremists will
argue
that
the west did not come to help people who
when they were in need and that
coexistence is impossible and we can
stop that argument and stop giving that
argument to terrorists by getting
humanitarian aid we did it in zimbabwe
when we disagreed with the regime we're
doing it in other countries where there
are people in peril i think we've got to
admit that this is the biggest
humanitarian crisis of our times
and if we do nothing
we're talking about the lives of
hundreds of thousands of people and
perhaps millions are put at risk through
starvation and mr brown can you give us
any hope on that front is there any
cause for even a slight degree of
optimism that we may get this pledging
conference or certainly a virtual one as
soon as we possibly can
well i've heard to the foreign secretary
weeks ago and i'm waiting for a reply
i i i do think that britain has a
particular look as he here we want to
show that we are a global power
and i think
we can work with the european union and
co-convene such a conference uh i i
think america probably is the it will
join it but i don't think they'll be the
leaders of it the organization of
islamic states i think will want to be
part of it because they've already
pledged that they want to do something
britain gave just over 90 million last
week but that is not enough we're
talking about 4 billion and more that is
actually needed and martin griffis who's
the u.n coordinator a person who was a
british civil servant at one point i
mean he knows just how big that need is
and how it's got to be met urgently and
it's about time our government officials
listen to what he is saying and what
he's learning on the ground and take the
action that is that is necessary this is
a humanitarian disaster
unveiled before our eyes and the picture
that's pictures that you've presented
this evening
showed just the scale of the suffering
and the needless loss of lives and it is
not only heartbreaking but as i said it
makes me angry to see that so little is
being done to avoid unnecessary
suffering babies die for many reasons
but they should not be dying because of
starvation and because they're frozen to
death